L
AND SAVANOK
WALKEMPAIGN,
YOSE VOTES OUT
JEFF ZELENY WAS R GREAT
POINT AND WEWE WCH ESCOUNTIES.
YOU PICK A .
THEY'RE AT 67%.U SEE THES65%.
BUT RAWS.
C
YOUOT TO OFFSET  IT'S ONLY 1,30.
ALES RIGHTNOW.
A MONTHAGT WAS VOTES.
IT ISN'T ENOH CLOSE.
YOAT AGT IS PROBABLY DOWN
EVERRE
THE QUESTION CAN YO OVER HERE
WE'RE AT IN THE RUN-OF
PUT THE RAWNUTH JUST SEE.
A MONTH AGO,79.SO A TE DIFREBA,T
USE ARE
THEM.MACO
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
DROP YOUENOUGH?
TON.USE AS YO THER T WE ARETODA.
ALUND THE
>> C
LARGEST E STA
TONHERE.
Y.
COUNTY  THE SECOND LAR
55% HE
YOU MOVE DOWN YO FOURT
COUNTY.
>> THERE ARE A TON OF DEMRATICT.
>> WEO MHER
O THE NITTY  WOULD RE
AHEAD THAN HI
AGO, IE 'S OOW ON, A
RACE, ARESIDENTIAL  A IS BLUE.
>>HENYO THE ING VOTE
>> GE
RACE.
BACKO EE OUTA
WAITITE S.
BIG BLUEOTAT ITLM LIKEUST
ONE.
BUT AC THERE ARER OUT.E FOR TURO
YOU.
YOU CAN STRETCH THATOUT.
FULTOL
>> IF THEY WERE SPREAD OUTI'MTYI